wenn sie sagen dass jeder der verhandeln
will Putins Propaganda verbreitet dann
verbreitet offenbar also auch der Papst
gut ins Propaganda dann verbreitet der
brasilianische Präsident Putins
Propaganda dann verbreitet sogar die
RAND Corporation die ja gegründet wurde
um die US-Army zu beraten
putinpropaganda weil auf die RAND
Corporation hat vor kurzem eine Studie
veröffentlicht wo sie sehr deutlich
warnt dass beiden nicht seine bisherige
Strategie fortsetzen soll auf einen
langen abnutzungskrieg mit immer mehr
Waffenlieferung zu setzen weil das sagt
die randkooperation und ich werde hier
hingestellt wie jemand der von Putin
bezahlt wird wenn ich sowas fordere also
das ist doch irre die deutsche Debatte
ist doch wirklich verrückt also wenn
Leute die Fliegen
genau
so propagiert die sind die Reaktionen
auf unserer Manifest sind aber witzig
[Musik]